Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
emisión especial de nuestro programa
desde tu luz la llamada ciudad rosa en
el suroeste de Francia en Carrusel de
las artes hoy daremos un vistazo al cine
latinoamericano y a la música francesa
[Música]
regresa el festival cine latino de tulus
como siempre con una selección de
películas recientes venidas de América
Latina que compiten por los premios en
largometrajes cortos y documentales en
2023 cine latino pone el acento en la
producción cinematográfica colombiana el
cine político de Brasil y destaca el
trabajo de aquellas actrices que se han
lanzado a la dirección y en París
descubriremos a los walteas astral un
Dúo musical hippie que nos transporta a
un universo espacial y psicodélico
[Música]
Carrusel de las artes se encuentra en el
festival cine latino de tu luz uno de
los festivales en Francia más
importantes para el cine latinoamericano
son 10 días en los que se proyectan 150
películas en diferentes salas de la
ciudad y sus alrededores
cine latino es una fiesta con encuentros
música y una competencia en
largometrajes de ficción cortos y
documentales pero también una
oportunidad para descubrir a través del
cine la complejidad y riqueza cultural
de América Latina
[Música]
el festival fue creado por esta razón
porque el cine tiene esta capacidad de
llevar imaginarios desde América Latina
una audiencia muy amplia porque el cine
es el arte más popular año tras año ese
espejo vuelve a ser más preciso porque
hay más diversidad dentro de la
comunidad de los directores y de las
directoras con gente que tienen otro
background que vienen de comunidades de
pueblos indígenas o más directoras o
personas que no que no vienen del mundo
de cine y que llevan con ellos nuevas
historias nuevos rostros nuevos cuerpos
y nuevas y realidades este espejo no
funciona solamente en documental Pero
por supuesto la ficción incluido cuando
no trata de manera frontal un asunto
refleja de una manera problemáticas
íntimas o personal o familiar y que que
hace parte de esta realidad americana
por las cosas importantes que hacemos
siempre lo deseamos demasiado tarde
tarde once películas compiten en la
categoría largometrajes de ficción en
cine latino una de ellas es la peruana
diógena es una película en blanco y
negro que se hizo realidad gracias a
este festival
diógenes nos transporta a los Andes
peruanos donde dos hermanos son criados
en el más puro aislamiento por su padre
un pintor de tablas una mañana diógenes
no se despierta Sabina y Santiago
conviven durante tres días con el
cadáver de su padre se trata de la
primera película de Leonardo barbui La
idea nació a raíz de un sueño en el que
yo tenía algunas imágenes de mi infancia
cuando iba a la sierra peruana de unas
pequeñas casas en las montañas casas de
pastoreo y en mi sueño Yo me acercaba
una de esas casas y había un hombre
muerto que no conocía un nombre andino y
pues yo tengo dos hijos trabajo con
infancias también Y pensé que duro Sería
para un par de niños
viviendo en aislamiento pues presenciar
la muerte de su padre y descubrir la
muerte a raíz de eso no y ahí empezó a
surgir la idea de la película y bueno
Luego tuvimos la oportunidad de acercar
al pueblo de sarhua y durante cinco años
hicimos un trabajo en conjunto con el
pueblo para conocer mucho más acerca de
las relaciones de vida las relaciones
con la muerte con la crianza etcétera
dentro del pueblo la película termina
siendo el resultado de este sueño y el
vínculo con con el pueblo de Starbucks
diógenes es una perla visual de
contraste Sublime es una cinta apoyada
por la plataforma sin en construcción de
tu luz y que habla sutilmente de la
historia convulsa de Perú la película
guarda una relación con los periodos de
violencia no en relación al conflicto
armado interno entre los 80s y noventas
pero también específicamente de lo que
trata es de la post violencia no la
película ha cobrado una vigencia mucho
mayor en el contexto peruano actual en
donde Pues el abuso de poder sistemático
el racismo el clasismo este
todas todas esas problemáticas
estructura están socavando de una manera
pues muy fuerte muy agresiva el país
actualmente no entonces pues siento que
la película también nos ayuda a
reflexionar sobre un periodo que no
solamente tiene que ver con una mirada
en relación al pasado sino de una manera
muy fuerte con el presente también
este año sin el latino destaca la
trayectoria de varias mujeres que
comenzaron en el cine Como actrices y
han pasado detrás de las cámaras es el
caso de la chilena Manuela martelli
quien presentó aquí en cine latino su
primera película Como directora
el público la descubrió en 2003 con be
happy y luego con la exitosa Machuca de
Andrés Wood películas que se vieron en
cine latino en 2023 Manuela martelli
vino a tu luz con un nuevo rol el de ser
cineasta y guionista de 1976 una cinta
sobre la dictadura pero desde lo
femenino yo siempre quise dirigir en
parte por eso es que me puse a actuar no
interesaba mucho el cine quería conocer
un set de cine y bueno fue la manera No
Y ahí seguía actuando después pero el
proceso de para llegar a dirigirse nueve
setenta y seis fue largo fueron siete
años siete años en los que por un lado
yo estaba Aprendiendo a escribir un
guión y por otro también estábamos
intentando producir financiar una
película que era una primera película de
época entonces tenía digamos ciertas
pretensiones para una primera película
Manuela martelli forma parte de un grupo
de cuatro mujeres presentes este año en
tu luz que han sido actrices y se
volcaron a la dirección con todas las
dificultades que eso supone Siempre hubo
mujeres dirigiendo desde los principios
del cine y todas esas mujeres
fueron bastante opacadas digamos al
mismo tiempo creo que muy pocas mujeres
tenían posibilidades tenían acceso a
dirigir era un ambiente muy masculino
y lleno de
restricciones para las mujeres digamos
que hayan cuatro mujeres actrices
dirigiendo de es una cosa bastante
particular
es un buen síntoma no estoy muy
agradecida de que seamos reconocida
de eso todo lo que tenía que hacer
[Música]
Brasil y los cambios políticos desde los
años 60 es una temática fuerte este año
en cine latino el festival Presenta una
selección de películas para entender
como el cine ha sido un reflejo de la
historia y de la complejidad en ese país
aprovechando el cambio político con el
regreso a la presidencia de Lula da
Silva sin el latino compuso Este
programa que explora la producción
brasileña desde los años del cine novo
hasta películas más actuales filmadas
por aforo brasileños historias de
resistencia rebelión fantasía
[Música]
vimos los últimos cuatro años momentos
muy duros y únicos de nuestra historia
de un gobierno de extrema derecha
entonces estas películas son 8 películas
cuentan una de esas películas una
película histórica importantísima de sol
exhibida inversión restaurada una nueva
copia exhibida acá por primera vez las
otras películas fueron hechas después de
los años 2000 y cuentan
enseñan con distintas perspectivas voces
estilos poéticas la situación brasileña
los cambios en la sociedad pero también
asumen posturas políticas distintas de
una manera diría bastante polifónica
hacemos un retrato del Brasil actual del
cine brasileño actual y ofrecemos
caminos para que el público pueda
entender mejor esta situación
creo que ahora podemos seguir el camino
que el cine brasileño ya venía tomando
un camino no solo de diversidad y
pluralidad de Voces pero también un
camino de cooperación internacional no
como retomar las políticas de
coproducción con América Latina tenemos
una misión bastante dura porque el país
también Hoy está muy dividido el
audiovisual tiene un poder grande de
también concientizar las personas y eso
espero no que volvamos a producir que
volvamos a tener los fondos una
diversidad una polaridad que nuevas
cineastas que estaban empezando con
cortos con medios pueden llegar a hacer
sus largos que se vuelva a apoyar la
difusión de las películas en Brasil y en
el mundo también
[Música]
dejamos ahora cine latino de tu luz para
ir a París de la mano de nuestra colega
Natalia Olivares que nos presenta en
esta ocasión a un dúo excéntrico de la
escena musical francesa Hola Natalia
Hola María Carolina si tú crees que
hemos vuelto a la capital pues no
estamos en un mundo de fantasía
actualmente con los Walter astral y su
disco y perduino dos druidas
completamente loco que nos llevan en un
torbellino de sonido un torbellino
psicodélico Bienvenidos a la aventura
con Cristo y tinuco
el espacio
[Música]
ese pueblo
los elementos naturales eran muy
evidentes a la hora de componer
estábamos en medio la naturaleza cuando
nos pusimos a escribir el disco por lo
que estos temas nos llegaron como algo
natural Todo esto nos motivó las ideas
que eran inmediatas y precisas para los
sonidos y canciones
a este pequeño bosque donde tengo un
estudio que está lleno de seres
fantásticos de druidas ideadas y así
compusimos nuestro primer disco
el roxicodélico de Tino Y el gurú
técnico de tristón hacen esa alquimia
loca centrada en temas cósmicos y en los
cuatro elementos agua fuego aire y
tierra
por ejemplo no tengo el aspecto pop que
tiene Tino no es lo mío vengo de la
música tecno que es una música que debe
durar y llevar al público a un estado de
trance mientras que tu utino tienes una
forma más pop de ver la música Vienes de
una banda mucho más popular
yo diseño las canciones de una manera
más clásica con un formato mucho más
tradicional y los dos universos juntos
crearon algo nuevo y loco el disco es
algo que parece un poco loco pero su
partitura es extremadamente estudiada y
el resultado es el cuerpo baila y la
cabeza no sabe por qué
Tratamos de liberar ese lado absurdo que
todos tenemos somos una especie de
potenciadores de la locura de la
espontaneidad llamamos a la gente a
expresar su locura sin vergüenza a que
se transformen en druidas por ejemplo
vengan con nosotros todos somos magia
[Música]
Gracias natalio Olivares y con la música
de Los Walter astral vamos a despedir
Este programa especial que les
presentamos desde la ciudad de tu luz
Muchísimas gracias por su sintonía y
hasta la próxima
[Música]